[Music]  i am really excited  about this panel with the filmmakers  nominated for best first teacher  at the spirit awards in a lot of ways it  felt like jumping  off a cliff i shot my film in the  neighborhood in which i grew up  folks in that neighborhood were like  determined and they had grit  and they showed could dress that  informed the style all of that work i  did as an actor  when you kind of fill your character  with these unseen truths  i bring so much of that to directing  it's not very different from making a  short film all the knowledge that you  have  but making a short film is more or less  like everything that you need  if i'm ever in the position of having  power  i'm going to do my best to remain kind  and i think it's because  i was a pa on many of many assets where  a person wasn't kind  every single one of you made a film that  i absolutely adore